금리가 거의 막 1.5% 이상
[음악]
내려갔어요네 안녕하세요 빌사남 있니다
제가 오늘은 빌딩 대출에 대해서
궁금해하시는 분들이 많아서 제가
실제로 대출을 받았거든요 최근에 좀
대한 대출을 하면서 제가 느꼈던
경험들이 노하우들을 좀 한번 영상으로
담아 보도록 하겠습니다 우선 빌딩
대출을 받으려면 한 다섯 가지 정도를
좀 생각을 하셔야 돼요 그래서 일단
첫 번째가 대입 주체 개인이냐
법인이냐 따라서 대출 금액이
달라집니다 법인 같은 경우에는 rti
규제를 받지 않아요 쉽게 설명드리면
임대 수익이 나오지 않은 건물들을
매입할 때 법인으로 매입하는 경우에는
대출이 잘 나옵니다 그래서 많은
분들이 신규법인을 설립해서 또 많이
매입을 해요 그래서 이제 신규 법인을
설립을 하는데 여러분들이 아셔야 될게
신규법인을 미리 설립하시고 그런
경우에는 만약에 오래 안 살 수도
있잖아요 내년에 매입했을 때 재무제표
에 매출이 없다 보니까 오히려 대출이
더 안 나옵니다 일단은 개인으로
매입해 놓고 잔금 전에 법인으로
전환할 수 있다라는 특약 사항을 좀
넣어 놔요 일단은 매물 사는게 첫
번째고 법인 설립해서 그 뒤에 절차로
하시면 됩니다 일단 아셔야 될게
법인이 대출이 잘 나오고 미리 설립할
필요는 없고 매물 잡는게 일단
우선이고 그다음에 이제 법인 설립해서
그때 이제 전환하시면 됩니다 두
번째는 감정 가액에 따라서 대출
금액이 달라집니다 감정 가액이 높게
나오는 지역들이 있어요 그래서 주변에
매각된 사례가 많더라는 매매 금액이랑
감정 가액이란 크게 차이가 안 났을
때 대출이 좀 잘 나오고 그리고 이제
지역마다 담보 인정 비율이 달라요
강남구는 보통 한 65% 70% 쯤
안 되는데 강남구가 지방이다 그래고
하면 담보 인정 비율이 다릅니다
그래서 이거를 예를 들면 은행에서도
이렇게 분석을 해요 나중에 이제
경매에 들어갔을 때 내가 잘 돈을
받을 수 있을까 이런 비율들을 다
정해 놓거든요 지역마다 지역마다 담보
인정 비율이 다르기 때문에 뭐이
부분도 좀 기억하시면 좋을 거
같습니다 세 번째는 용도에 따라 좀
달라져요 보통 이제 저희가 흔히
얘기하는 뭐 글린 생활 시설 빌딩
같은 경우에는 제가 말씀드린 대로 뭐
대출이 되게 잘 나오는데 만약에
주택이 들어가 있으면 주택 방마다
최우선 변제금이 다 까집니다 그래서
주택 건물은 대출이 좀 많이 안
나와요 그래서 여러분들이 건물 매입할
때 용도가 글린 생활 시설 건물인지
주택 건물인지 뭐이 부분은 좀
기억하시면 좋을 거 같고 그네 번째는
기존 사업체가 있으면 대출이 잘
나옵니다 예를 들어서 내가 기존의
법인을 운영하고 있고 내 메인 사업이
있으면 4억을 매입한다고 하면 대출이
잘 나와요 은행에선 그냥 부동산
임대업으로 돼 있으면은 대출이 되게
안 나옵니다 조건도 안 좋 근데
만약에 내가 기존에 뭐 제조업을 하고
있고 이걸로 이제 사업을 매입하려고
한다라고 하면 진짜 대출 조건이 말도
안 되게 잘 나옵니다 최근에도 저희가
대출을 했었는데 의류 사업 같은 거
하시는 분인데 사업 매입 한다라고
하니까 금리뿐만 아니라 대출 금액도
많이 나오고 금리도 한 3% 대로
받았거든요 그래서 이것처럼 메인
사업이 있는 경우에는 대출 조건이 좀
되게 잘 나온다네 이렇게 보시면 될
거 같고 그리고 다섯 번째는 연
말보다는 연초가 대출 조건이 되게
좋아요 그거는 보통 이제 연초에 임대
사업자 대출 한도를 좀 정해 놔요
연말에 갈수록 대출 한도가 줄어듭니다
그래서 진짜 연말에 대출이 안 나올
수도 있고 조건이 매우 안 좋을 수도
있어요 그래서 만약에 내가 뭐 11월
12월쯤 계약한다고 하면 차라리 대출
기간을 내년으로 늘리는게 낫습니다 뭐
예를 들어서 1월이 됐든 2월이 됐든
여기서 아셔야 될 거는 1월 초 같은
경우에는 인사 이동이 좀 많거든요
그래서 1월 중순부터 잔금 기간을
정하시면 좋을 것 같아요 그리고 또
하나 아셔야 될게 은행마다 달긴
하겠지만 이제 대체적으로 보면은
상반기 시작 이제 하반기 시작하는
때쯤부터 조건이 좀 괜찮더라고요
그래서 예를 들어서 뭐 7월
1일부터는 대출 조건이 다른 월가
비교 위해서는 좀 괜찮긴 하더라고요
요것도 한번 좀 보시면 좋을 거 같고
그리고 이게 시기마다 은행마다 조건이
좀 달라요 이벤트들을 하는 경우도
있고 그래서 여러분들이 은행마다
이렇게 지점장님들을 좀 많이 알고
계시는게 되게 중요한 거 같아요 더
나아가서는 이런 쿠폰들 있어요 저희가
상품 3에 이렇게 쿠폰 주는 것처럼
쿠폰을 몇 개 주거든요 저도 지금
최근에 대한 대출 했던 것도 쿠폰으로
했는데 금리 조건을 너무 잘 받았어요
제가 여기서 공개할 순 없지만 그래서
여러분들이은 행마다 지점장님들을 잘
알아 놓으면 되게 좋은 조건에 받을
기회도 좀 생깁니다 요런 것도
있다라고 좀 알고 계시면 좋을 거
같고 기존에 내가 대출을 받았는데
2년 정도 지나면 중도 상한 수수료가
그렇게 크진 않거든요 그리고 이제
3년 정도는 중도 상한 수수료가 없기
때문에 기존의 은행을 연장할 수도
있겠지만 대체적으로 보면은 대환대출이
오히려 금리가 더 싸요 대한 대출
최근에 했던 거는 물론 쿠폰도 썼지만
금리가 거의 막 1.5% 이상
내려갔어요 만약에 내가 대출 든지
3년이 넘었다고 하면 여러분들 대한
대출을 좀 적극적으로 알아보셔야
됩니다 진짜 막 1% 이상 내려가는
경우를 너무 많이 받거든 금액이
커질수록 1% 금리가 진짜 엄청
큽니다 만약에 내가 대출 받은지 뭐
3년이 넘었다고 하면 대환 대출을 좀
알아보시면 좋을 거 같고 그리고
마지막으로 또 이런 거 많이
물어보세요 그래서 내가 메이프 뭐
리모델링이나 신축하려는 그것도 대출이
되냐라고 얘기를 많이 하시는데 그것도
이제 시설 자금 대출로 대출이
나옵니다 법인으로 받으면 제가 봤을
때는 최소 그래도 공사비 한 60%
이상은 나옵니다 그래서 저도 받았던
거는 최근에 한 70% 정도 받았었고
요것도 시설 자금 대출 명목으로 좀
나온다라고 보시면 될 거 같습니다
신규 법인으로 많이 산다라고 했잖아요
근데 신규 법인으로 살 때 보통은
이제 아무래도 재무제표가 없다 보니까
대표자 신용을 좀 많이 봅니다
대표자를 좀 어떤 분을 할지를
고민하시면 좋을 거 같고 계속
얘기하니까 계속
나오네 그래서 진짜 마지막으로 만약에
내가 내가 a 아는 은행에 하려고
한다라고 하면 기간을 가지시고 예를
들어서 뭐 일정 금액을 좀 예치해
놓으면 은행 등급이 좀 올라가요 그럼
조건이 또 좋아지거든요 작업할 기간이
좀 필요합니다 내가라는 은행에서 받을
예정이다고 하면 그 은행 지점장님
얘기를 해서 일정 금액은 좀 거기
예치해 두세요 상품 같은 거 있으면
좀 가입도 하시고 좀 은행 등급을
높여 놓으면 잔금 기간이 됐을 때
좋은 조건에 받을 수 있습니다 일단
세부적으로 들어가면 좀 더 깊어 긴
하는데 그래도 웬만한 내용은 다
말씀드렸어요요 부분을 참고하셔 가지고
딩
매입하시나요
진짜 3% 대도 나오고 있고 많은
분들이 좀 되게 궁금해하실 것 같은데
제가 말씀드렸던 거 좀 참고하셔
가지고 빌딩 투자하는데 도움이
되셨으면 좋겠습니다 그래서 오늘 영상
여기까지 하고요 다음 시간에 뵙도록
하겠습니다 감사합니다
[음악]
h